dans cette lisez qu'en banlieue de
détroit l'avalanche a déjà commencé on
s'assure de ne pas manquer de matériel
médical
car depuis vendredi les appels de
partout aux états-unis n'arrête pas du
jour au lendemain le michigan s'est
transformée en état sanctuaire my friend
and taxes
annexes mon ami au texas a dû fermer
tout si clean et qui raconte rené
syrienne mixe les sectes
les trois cliniques de knowlton famille
planning procède à environ 9000
avortements par an un chiffre qui
grimpera probablement en flèche du moins
c'est à ce scénario que rené se prépare
il faudra embaucher plus de médecins
expliqué l'emea tout pour éviter de
fermer la porte au nez d'une patiente
dans le besoin rené ne se le
pardonnerait pas
car pour elle le combat et personnel
la septuagénaire s'est fait avorter en
1966 lorsque c'était encore illégal ou
michy quand
on nous bandait les yeux nous mettait
dans une voiture et on nous a menés dans
un entrepôt abandonné raconte-t-elle
from each day
et prixmac
pendant sa carrière la docteur lisa
harris a accompagné des dizaines de
femmes qui se sont fait avorter
la gynécologue d'origine canadienne se
réjouit claude michy non plus servir
d'état sanctuaire mais avec ce statut
viendra une pression sur le système de
santé
[Musique]
gramsci quart d'heure il n'y a pas que
les professionnels de la santé qui
essaient de s'organiser gardien guy
nathan pro choisira les portes de sa
maison aux femmes qui voyageront aussi
gants pour se faire avorter
oui
j'ai grandi dans une famille de témoins
de jéhovah elle est toujours des
étrangers chez moi dans ce qu'elle
le michigan a beau vouloir devenir un
état sanctuaire l'accès à l'avortement
est aussi menacée et si l'état devait
choisir d'adopter des lois plus
restrictives beaucoup d'américaines
pourrait choisir de se tourner vers le
canada de l'autre côté de la rivière
des perles et directrice de théâtre
féministe à windsor la petite maison
dans sa cour faisait jusqu'à présent
office de résidence d'artistes
l'espace sera maintenant réservées aux
américaines qui voudront se faire
avorter au canada
d'expression
à ce fin connaisseur viennent après si
l'élan de solidarité canadien mais elle
n'y voit qu'une solution temporaire tous
très peu de femmes pourront se permettre
d'être validé tous travaux
la seule option pour rené et de
continuer à se battre dans un pays de
plus en plus polarisé ou l'avortement
divise plus que jamais des swan mais
swiss et wafa s'inclinait cas d'ailleurs
dû resserrer ses mesures de sécurité
rien pour décourager la militante
un combat long et difficile mais
nécessaire croit-elle pour que les sig
en reste un état sanctuaire une porte
ouverte pour les femmes qui n'auront pas
d'autre choix et si la semaine média
radio canada au michigan